IS THAT A FULL BODY SHOT OF OLMEC? I'VE NEVER SEEN HIS LOWER HALF.
IS THIS A LEGENDS
OF THE HIDDEN TEMPLE TELL-ALL?
- DUDE, PROBABLY.
EVERYTHING COOL
COMES FROM MEXICO.
YOU KNOW, TACOS AND...
- WHERE'S YOUR BLANKET THOUGH?
- SICK.
- OH, HEY.
THESE RIGHT HERE IN THE BAG,
THEY'RE IN A BAG FOR A REASON.
THEY ARE MUY CALIENTE--
BURNING YOUR SKIN OFF.
DON'T LET 'EM TOUCH YOU.
ALL RIGHT?
- ALL RIGHT. SWEET.
- AWESOME.
THIS RIGHT HERE
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
I NEED TO ASK A FAVOR OF YOU.
- THANK YOU.
- I HAVE A BUSINESS ASSOCIATE
STOPPING BY TOMORROW
TO PICK THAT UP.
DON'T OPEN IT.
IT SAYS IT RIGHT THERE.
- IT DOES. RIGHT ON THE FRONT.
- I READ THAT TOO,
BUT I WAS LIKE,
"IT'S LIKE A SUGGESTION."
BUT I REALLY WANT TO KNOW,
"WHAT'S IN THE BOX?
WHAT'S IN THE BOX?"
LIKE FROM THAT SCARY MOVIE,
SEVEN? WITH BRAD PITT?
- I'M SORRY.
I HAVEN'T SEEN MOVIES.
BUT I KNOW WHO BRAD PITT IS.
I SEE HIS FACE
ON THE MAGAZINE BLANKETS
THAT KEEP ME WARM AT NIGHT.
- MAGAZINE BLANKETS.
- OKAY, BUT, LIKE,
WHAT IS IN THE BOX ACTUALLY,
THOUGH?
- WE DON'T WANT TO KNOW
WHAT'S IN THE BOX, OKAY?
DON'T TELL US, 'CAUSE WE'RE NOT
SOME SHADY FEDEX KINKOS
WITH PACKAGE PICKUP
AVAILABILITY, OKAY?
- OKAY, WELL I HAVE 2,000
REASONS THAT SAYS OTHERWISE.
THESE ARE ALL DOLLARS.
- OH. WELL, HELL YEAH.
WE'LL DO IT. COME ON.
- OH, MY GOSH.
- GIVE ME THE MONEY.
- I'LL GIVE YOU ONE G NOW
AND THEN ANOTHER G
UPON COMPLETION, OKAY?
- I LOVE THAT YOU'RE GIVING US
MONEY, BUT IT'S Ts.
IT'S NOT Gs.
- HMM?
- IT'S THOUSANDS.
NOT GROUSANDS.
HMM?
- OH, WOW.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN Gs IN MY BOOK.
LET ME CHANGE THAT.
- I'M GLAD I'M HERE
TO TEACH YOU SOMETHING.